Game of Thrones Season eight is the most
anticipated TV release of 2019 and HBO
has been super secretive about the
production but it looks like some
footage has leaked from the new season
revealing surprising twists in the
future of Jon Snow so CI a-- and others
in this lake shot
it looks like jon is captured by
Dothraki just like Daenerys was in
season six jon is then forced to fight
as a gladiator in what looks like Dez
knacks pit in Mereen it is surprising
that John is here in the East instead of
fighting White Walkers in Westeros but
this Ark seems important for Jon
personally because there's this dream
sequence with Jon and Ned Stark
the man who Jon thinks as his father
John tries to free Ned from chains while
the mountain swings a sword around with
a triangle on his head the theme here is
that Jon feels trapped in his
responsibilities when his true passion
is to train and become the top-ranked
professional tennis player in Westeros
as well as a three-time cover model for
Men's Health magazine black culture ago
before him so this is a surprising but
inspiring conclusion to John's story in
season 7 Queen Cersei plans to hire a
mercenary army to help her win Westeros
and in this league shot she gets her
army and Cersei personally leads them to
battle but this might go badly for her
because it looks like Circe's wounded
and even loses an eye who does this to
her
well I a Stark wants to kill Cersei and
here we see aya wearing crimson and gold
maybe she uses her faceless magic to
infiltrate the Lannisters join their
army and try to assassinate Cersei but
Cersei won't go down easy
she upgrades her ballista to a minigun
and goes all neo on stark horses
luckily Hodor returns to stop her but
aya flees the war to take up a life of
crime with a strange old man
Sansa gets fed up with being the only
Stark who doesn't have a superpower like
is a shape-shifting ninja brands a
psychic and Jon can't bloody die so
Sansa decides to learn
Kinesis and the power of flight we see
her explode with fire and light finally
confirming that Sansa is azor Ahai the
prophesied hero who will save Westeros
this is a dramatic change in Sansa's
destiny but she remains loyal to her
family because her new tattoo is of a
direwolf representing a love for House
Stark last season Daenerys embraced her
power as a Targaryen queen but she still
seems torn in her identity here she
wears white fur with a red scarf tight
around her neck
the scarf represents Danny's role as a
Targaryen Queen well the white fur
refers to the white Lions coat Danny
wears in the books in her role as
Khaleesi so Danny feels torn between her
past and her future her solution is to
reject both instead of using Mighty
Targaryen dragons as her weapons Danny
decides to just shoot cons guns are way
easier to manage than dragons and this
saves HBO money on expensive CGI so
expect fewer dragons in season 8 last
time we saw Jaime
he left Cersei and rode north but it
looks like his breakup with his lifelong
lover really hurts Jaime emotionally he
ends up changing his look with a
handlebar mustache and some highly
symbolic tattoos the name Catherine may
refer to Catelyn who Jaime swore an oath
to in season one this image of a
beheading may refer to Ned Stark who
Jaime attacked before Ned's death and
this cross may refer to the inn at the
crossroads where Catelyn captured Tyrion
and sparked the Lannister stark war so
these tattoos are a tapestry of Jaime's
feelings of guilt to the Starks but it
also refers to his own family
this spiderweb design refers to Jaime's
great-grandmother rohan of house weber
look it up nerds
so Jaime's tattoos represent the
conflicts that will define him and his
mustache in the season to come in season
7 Tyrion tried to help his queen through
strategic advice all of which failed
disastrously so it looks like next
season Tyrion tries to use other skills
like his combat prowess and business
acumen
but ultimately Tyrion does a rata gassed
and retires to the woods to become a
bearded hermit maybe he wasn't cut out
for the Game of Thrones after all Cal
[ __ ] Tanner and Al arias and seemed
dead but now it looks like they're alive
running a tech startup in Cardiff Gilly
decides to break up with Sam and moves
to Bristol to shack up with Gendry Sam
is so heartbroken that he joins the
faith hot pie started the series as an
amoral bully before growing into a
slightly more virtuous character that
sadly the leaks show hot pie returning
to petty crime stealing an ice cream
cone from a small child it turns out
that Margaery survived Circe's wildfire
last season with only her hair burned
off she gets a Tyrell tattoo to
commemorate her dead family The Hound
suffers a tragic head injury bran
finally gets the retirement he always
wanted and Tywin suffers in his own
personal hell for his crimes against
Westeros so this looks to be a bold
season aid we're getting surprising
twists in major storylines and some
fresh new character makeovers but it's a
shame that all this footage was leaked
you think that by now HBO would fix
their online security Thrones season 5
was hacked in 2015 then again in 2017
HBO must be using insecure passwords or
something they should get a password
manager like - Lane - Lane automatically
generates and remembers secure passwords
for all your sites it even has a breach
alert feature so if you get hacked
you'll be notified before all your
episodes leaked so - Lane's security is
great for TV networks but it's also
important for youtubers businesses and
anyone who wants their logins and
transactions safe the app is secure easy
to use and free so sign up to - Lane at
the link below this helps support alt
shift X and helps you stay secure you
can also upgrade to a premium membership
which syncs across devices using our
offer code to get 10% off so don't be
like HBO secure your data with our
sponsor - Lane thank you for watching
and
thanks to the patrons including Ayesha
Solomon Ashley Watts Johari Ismail and
Lola play Cheers
you